thank you so I thought I'd start with
maybe a question which is what on earth
and how the Stanford have currently
currently this quarter a hundred and
sixty three entrepreneurship and
innovation courses and the most
interesting question for at least the
next hour is and why the heck am i
teaching three of them and so to answer
that question believe it or not we need
to go back 75 years for world war two
and we're gonna take a look in this talk
at four areas that kind of drove
Stanford's innovation and
entrepreneurship but in the 50s and 60s
Stanford was a cold war university
startups and venture capital emerging
not only outside the university but
driven by a single professor inside the
university lean methodology which I and
others helped to invent and then promote
and then things going on outside the
universities control and actually
outside the control the country
disruptive adversaries so let me start
with the idea of the Cold War University
Stanford and the 40s 50s and 60s
seventy-five years ago when world war ii
started a scientist named Vannevar bush
had a really interesting idea he took to
the President of the United States he
said look up until now the only people
who built military weapons systems were
military laboratories that's how it
worked in the United States his insight
was that World War two was going to be a
technology war and that civilians could
make better weapons in service of their
country than the military could and of
course anyway I could guess what the
military said they laughed and what but
the guy was so persuasive they cut a
deal with the president they were going
to allow civilian scientists to build
weapon systems that have the most
advanced
and the army and the Navy and the Army
Air Forces we're going to build
traditional weapons that's how we set up
technology in World War two and so
civilians were gonna focus on these new
technologies called electronics some
physics problems and advanced medical
problems and to do this the United
States set up an organization called the
office of scientific research and
development OSRD existed for six years
OS Rd had about a thousand direct
employees academics professors grad
students and about ten thousand of their
contractors and it built a series of
organizations that were scattered
throughout the best research
universities at the time in the United
States East Coast West Coast etc and
they set up 19 divisions five committees
two panels etc all focused on different
problems of radar and I submarine
warfare electronic warfare Chemical
Engineering ballistic research all
advanced technologies and they also
actually had a small physics problem
from Berkley that had 125,000 employees
when it was done and spent 26 billion
dollars on this problem which was so big
they spun it out of this organization
and resulted in some Applied Physics by
the end of the war so LS R&D was
responsible for spending a ton of money
and a bunch of interesting areas one of
the groups was something called
electronic warfare which just for short
was a way to confuse radar that was
trying to locate us airplanes and this
was a secret lab called the Harvard
radio research lab what's interesting is
had nothing to do with Harvard other
than it was there it had nothing to do
with radio and definitely had nothing to
do with research they were building
jammers electronic warfare equipment
that would go into every u.s. bomber and
flew over Europe and Japan to make the
planes essentially invisible to German
and Japanese radar so Harvard radio
Research Lab ran all electronic warfare
in World War two had 800 people question
was who ran this rule app the director
was an engineering professor from
Stanford named Fred Terman
Fred Terman built a lab of the best
microwave and electronics people people
could find at Harvard
because the guy who ran OSRD his PhD
thesis adviser Weiser Vannevar Bush
believes that besides Turman Stanford
had no other engineering talent worth
speaking of that was the state of
Stanford's engineering school circa
nineteen forty one tournament you could
come we think highly of you but just set
this thing up at Harvard because there's
nothing at Stanford keep that in mind
also keep in mind that before World War
two US universities research
universities regular universities got a
total of essentially zero dollars from
the federal government for research
essentially zero there was no federal
funding of science research in the
United States starting in World War two
OSRD these are in twenty sixteen dollars
gave out six billion dollars in the span
of three and a half years this was the
first time US universities tasted
federal money what do you think they
thought and by the way just for scale
who got most of it well
MIT got about a billion and a half
Caltech got 1.1 billion for rockets MIT
is money went mostly for radar Caltech
for Rockets Harvard 400 million Columbia
another 400 million for mostly
anti-submarine warfare and again just to
put in scale MIT a billion Stanford
here's how much they thought is Stanford
six million bucks for teacher training
for teacher training there was nothing
actually funded for Stanford in
engineering at all so just put that in
context by the way what happened to
orous R&D well some of you might be
familiar with what happened after World
War two it got broken up it got broken
up with universities thought hey this
idea of federal funding of science and
research this is a pretty good idea and
even Congress said we actually did get a
lot of interesting stuff out of having
civilians kind of work on the
problems and so the country decided that
we did need federal research
organizations and split up OSRD
into the National Science Foundation the
Atomic Energy Commission the Department
of Defense took a chunk and the NIH
National Institute of Health took back
all the medical panels in 1958 we added
two more federal research agencies
National Aeronautics and Space
Administration NASA and DARPA the
Defense Advanced Research Projects
Agency and the Atomic Energy Commission
in 1957 went over the department of
energy and so that's what happened with
federal research dollars now what's
interesting is what happened determined
here is a Stanford professor well
thought of by the East Coast Science
establishment but his school wasn't
thought of at all for engineering
prowess now what they didn't realize
when they did this determine said we
love you we hate your school not in so
many words as they forgot he was a
second-generation Stanford professor his
father invented or Co invented the IQ
test determined Binet IQ test so Turman
had grown up in Palo Alto grown up in
the Stanford culture and when he
returned from World War two he became
Dean of engineering at Stanford 1946 and
number one thing he said is we're never
going to be left out of government
dollars again ever
Stanford's going to become an
engineering powerhouse now it's just
like any startup going I'm going to take
on name of largest company that was the
silliest statement one could make at the
end of night end of 1945 1946 MIT just
got a billion dollars from the US
government and stare forgot money for
teacher training but Turman says look I
just collected the best engineers the
world had ever seen in microwaves and
electronics I built the most advanced
systems in fact there were factories
going 24/7
produced 24,000 jammers of his design
that went on every bloomer and went over
Europe so he wasn't just talking theory
he had actually built large-scale
production systems so he looked around
at his engineering staff at the radio
research lab at Harvard and said
congratulations I'm Dean of engineering
Stanford's a nice backwater school
congratulations all of you now have
tenure took his most senior members of
the radio research lab and made them
tenured academic faculty at Stanford and
by 1950 Stanford becomes the MIT of the
West now for the first time Stanford's
actually a player focused in microwaves
and electronics builds a electronics
research lab and works on unclassified
projects now in the United States the
Korean War was a real shock to the
country the Cold War is starting to kind
of cast a pall over the United States
and so determine at the request of the
US military sets up something called the
systems engineering lab and now does
applied and classified research doubles
the size of the military program and
makes the University for the full for
the first time a real partner in the
military-industrial complex now this was
not only going on at Stanford it was
going on in ND and every major research
university in the United States in the
50s and 60s all research universities in
the United States participated with the
US military in helping advance science
and military weapons systems and inside
of Stanford's engineering department
termined built a pretty impressive
organization here's what he did he sat
on every possible military advisory
board Turman was the ultimate Rainmaker
he built a network and relationships
between Stanford and every branch of the
military that needed electronics number
two he reached out to military customers
to understand their needs and then he
used Stanford's engineering school to
build prototype
we didn't get into manufacturing
military systems but he built
proof-of-concept prototypes what we
would call today Minimum Viable products
and it generated revenue for the
University and strengthened again their
military relationship third is if the
customer liked their prototype he did
something that no other University Dean
ever did to that point instead of his
encouraging his best students to become
academics he did something heretical he
said take our research take our
prototype and leave Stanford and start a
company unheard of in the 50s unheard
excuse me let's figure out is that guy
let's go all right let's go back
this inspired for the first time
entrepreneurship outside of the campus
for set of students and faculty that
just never had occurred before and he
put a stack as Stanford faculty member
or himself on the boards of these new
companies and this trained Stanford
faculty in business and turned them into
much better teachers and mentors for
these students and finally he helped
develop something called the Stanford
industrial park now the law at Stanford
was oh that was for commercial concerns
etc actually it was for his military
partners who wanted to take the fruits
of the Stanford systems engineering lab
and actually build military weapon
systems and ensured that the startups
actually stayed close to Stanford itself
the consequences Stanford became the
preferred contractor for electronic
warfare and electronic intelligence it
attracted temptin students but also
attracted military customers and started
a private investor ecosystem an academic
research and electronic intelligence and
electronic warfare was driven by
customer needs this is a big idea
determined for the first time was doing
customer discovery before I or anybody
else ever coined the term but the
downside for Stanford is by 1966 over a
third of the research funding for
electronics and engineering was for
classified projects inside of Stanford
and for those you know Stanford history
in 1968 the student riots forced out all
classified programs from inside Stanford
University and that was the beginning of
Turman and termina influence
so in summary Turman encouraged graduate
students
to start companies he encouraged
professors to consult for these
companies and terminan other professors
as I said earlier sat on board seats
Turman personally was on the board of
the first three IPOs public offerings in
Silicon Valley HP Varian and Watkins
Johnson and he made back then technology
and IP licensing easy
it wasn't an IP licensing office there
was an handshake with Fred Terman take
the IP built something great for the
country let us know that was it and
getting out and this was just an amazing
thing again in the 50s and 60s getting
out of academia was actually good for
your academic career and that was just a
bizarre concept to have in the 50s and
60s Stanford for the first time ever
became a outward-facing University led
by the engineering school and what I
mean by outward-facing is we started to
take into account the needs of Commerce
military customers and the outside world
now by the way Berkeley also had a great
engineering school also had great
activity with the military in World War
two I'll leave it as an exercise about
why didn't Berkeley's technology that
they developed in World War two become
outward-facing should think about that
so Stanford on the Cold War this was
Silicon Valley's first wave of
innovation we had great infrastructure
which meant we had great research
universities we had a predictable
economic system stable legal system 24/7
utilities you don't know how important
it is to have power on 24/7 until you're
a country that doesn't have it we had a
great culture our academic and
innovation culture kind of rewarded or
at least at the time didn't punish
risk-taking we were entrepreneurial as I
said we had outward facing universities
and a fleet free flow of people and
information what we didn't have at the
time were any innovation management
tools we'll get back to them and the
motivation at the time in the 50s and
60s for doing these startups was not
predict
we had to become a unicorn it was not
about money it was about a cold war
crisis and the entrepreneurial ecosystem
was from people who were building weapon
systems funding these spinouts at a
Stanford
there was no venture capital as we know
it there was no Sand Hill Road you've
got funded by your customer would either
prepay products or give you a contract
or give you what was called
non-recurring engineering but there was
no traditional venture capital and so
that was the state of Stanford in the
Cold War now what's interesting is
obviously in the 60s and 70s what
started to emerge were startups and a
venture capital ecosystem but
surprisingly it all started in one year
in 1956 in 1956 an airplane manufacturer
from Burbank California called the
Lockheed bid on and won a contract to
build something called
submarine-launched ballistic missiles
and that is think of these as rockets
that went inside of submarines
couldn't find a place in LA but they
found a great air base in the middle of
this valley called a valley of heart's
delight which just had mostly orchards
way before it was called Silicon Valley
and they built their facility in
Sunnyvale California and that company
was Lockheed they built the Polaris than
the Poseidon and the Trident missiles on
an assembly line in Sunnyvale now
Lockheed set up a special missiles and
division in Sunnyvale and just to give
you some scale about the impact that
Lockheed had way before most of you were
born is from the day they started that
division in 1956 in four years
they hired 20,000 employees just for
scale your you will attack 'red in 1960
had 3,000 people Silicon Valley had
turned into an arms merchant for the US
military
this was defense Valley and around the
Lockheed other subcontractors emerged
Westinghouse was building the launch
tubes out in Hunters Point lots of other
manufacturers sprung up and what's
interesting is what the Polaris was
understood and at least known what was
not known until 40 years later is that
Stanford and Lockheed were building spy
satellites at the same time so the lab
that Thurman had started electronic
intelligence to find radars and missile
telemetry was now building sub
satellites that were being launched by
Lockheed
into space Anna Lockheed was creating a
whole generation of electronic
intelligence satellites photo satellites
communications intelligence satellites
infrared detection satellites to see if
somebody else is launching missiles and
nuclear detection satellites to see if
anybody was testing nuclear weapons in
space now just for scale the largest
satellite that was built in Lockheed was
called hexagon the last film recovery
satellite that tube that's longer than a
school bus it's 60 feet long
we built a ton of these and lots of
other stuff that went in a space and the
interesting part is those sub satellites
were being designed and built by here at
Stanford now for the third piece of
entrepreneurship and that's startups and
venture capital on the other side of
town in 1956 someone named William
Shockley starts a company now I don't
know if any of you know Shockley's name
today it's not on a lot of things but in
world war ii he was director of naval
anti-submarine warfare at columbia and
then they moved over to the air force
and did radar bombing training but he's
mostly known if you're in technology is
the co-inventor the transistor and won
the Nobel Prize in 1956 but what he have
to do with Silicon Valley is he founded
the first transistor company the first
semiconductor company in Silicon Valley
now what's interesting about Shockley
was not that company what was
interesting about Shockley was he was a
great researcher probably the world's
best talent spotter and equally pretty
well known as the world's worst manager
in the history of Silicon Valley and the
reason why is he made life so miserable
for his eight best employees that they
all got up 15 months after he founded
the company and left
and they started a little company called
Fairchild Semiconductor
and two of those eight someone named
Gordon Moore and another guy named
Robert Noyce who had also gonna go off
and found Intel now what's interesting
about Shockley though in 1956 is every
other I said again every other
semiconductor company that was started
in Silicon Valley came from Shockley
so here's Shockley let me zoom out every
other silicon company came from this one
startup in 1956
now what started to happen about 20
years later was that private investors
noticed that there was some activity
going down south of San Francisco and
technology silicon semiconductors so
chip business this whole diagram now by
the mid 60s early 70s is getting kind of
interesting and while there was some
private money funding them some
customers funding them there was no
organized venture capital as we know it
today at best it could have been
described as angel capital and so what
happened is a couple of smart investors
decided to raise money from pension
funds private universities and wealthy
individuals called limited partners and
in 1978 and 1979 the US government
changed tool to tax rules that made this
actually pretty lucrative for all
parties one is the capital gains rate
was cut in half essentially from 48 to
25 percent but more importantly what was
called the prudent man rule for pension
funds that said you couldn't invest in
risky ventures was loosened so pension
funds who were sitting on billions of
dollars to invest were allowed to put up
the 10% of those dollars and for the
first time ever into venture capital
funds and VC funds until then which had
been kind of you know a couple hundred
grand maybe a million could now tap into
tens of millions of dollars and were
never available before and so what you
start seeing in
mid-seventies is people inventing this
form of venture capital called
two-and-twenty
the general partners would take 2% as a
management fee and keep 20% of the
profits and a whole set of firms started
emerge a couple of 1st of them were kind
of experiments but some of them you
might still recognize Patricof kleiner
perkins Sequoia all started building a
idea of a culture that would fund risky
ventures be patient through the failures
and make their money on the obscene
returns of the ones that succeeded no
unicorns yet not even for the next 25
years but it was the first time that
there was a financial asset class that
matched the passion and the vision of
the technology entrepreneurs and so
venture capital is actually now driving
this second wave of innovation in
Silicon Valley again we had great
infrastructure we had great culture we
still had no management tools but now
for the first time the motivation
instead of crisis was profit and instead
of getting military financing we were
now getting venture financing tied into
this profit cycle things are getting
interesting because now money is
starting to scale Silicon Valley so let
me take you through the third part which
is lean entrepreneurship now this is
where I come in
so I did eight startups in 21 years all
of them in the 20th century and the only
tool I had as a founder was this thing
anyway I recognize this says business
plan business plan was the book when
venture capitalist said go write a plan
you kind of looked at what everybody
else was doing and basically a business
plan was what you thought you were going
to do and it had a great appendix
Appendix A which had a five-year
forecast and surprisingly all of them
a hundred million dollars by year five
and in fact if you really think about it
a business plan still to today makes all
the sense in the world for your second
third or fifth product in a large
corporation because you have a series of
knowns but a business plan for a
start-up is really kind of different
because in a start-up you don't have a
series of knowns you have mostly a
series of unknowns and this is a big
idea because the only people in the 20th
century to require a five-year plan for
a series of unknowns were venture
capitalists than the Soviet Union that's
a joke okay write that down so one of
the other things we recognized as
entrepreneurs was that no business plan
survives first contact with customers
yet this was the only tool we had and it
kind of made sense because most venture
capitalists at the last quarter of the
20th century were either MBAs or
financial types and that's what they
grew up with and what's interesting was
there was clearly no distinction between
the tools of what a start-up would need
versus what a large company would need
we didn't even have a language to
distinguish this too so when I retired
after doing eight of these I started to
contemplate you know what worked and
what did it and what I realized was we
never even were able to articulate
something as simple as this startups are
not smaller versions of large companies
this believe it or not which seems like
duh was a heretical idea sixteen years
ago and even more so this was heretical
large companies execute known business
models right a large company knows its
customers knows its competitors knows
its channel knows pricing it knows that
because that's how it got large yes
stuff will change but yes we're large
because we know all that and we do a
great job of executing it but here was
the distinction startups don't execute
known business
models startups search for business
models this distinction between search
and execution and the history of
entrepreneurship had never been written
down if you would had asked
practitioners they would have said yeah
we know something's different we keep
getting fired or our company keep it's
not working but we don't know why and
the mistake we were making as
entrepreneurs were assuming that
everything we wrote in that plan somehow
magically translated into facts when all
we had were a series of untested
hypotheses and we were failing because
we were confusing what we should have
been doing which was searching for
business models but instead we were
executing them and so I realized that
startups needed their own tools
different from those used in existing
companies and so we came up with this
idea called the Lean Startup which is
simply a risk reduction methodology for
early-stage ventures nowadays not only
for startups but inside of large
companies as well as you'll see later
inside the government and the lean
startup has three simple components one
is let's take all our hypotheses or our
customers who are the stakeholders who
are the regulator's what are we building
for them
what are they needs what jobs they want
to get done what pains our gains this
who have a customer and what are you
building are the two most important
things in any market you need to figure
out and it has a special name called
product market fit
a mistake very bright founders make is
believing that because you implicitly
think you understand the problem on day
one you take some money and you go build
the solution and you ship the product
and the smarter you are the deeper the
hole you tend to dig one of the things I
learned painfully is that as smart as
you are there is no way you're smarter
than the collective intelligence of your
potential customers and they don't exist
inside your building so therefore there
are no facts inside your building so get
the heck out side we use this thing
called the business model canvas by
Alexander Osterwalder to kind of frame
the core commercialization hypotheses
early-stage ventures need to worry about
it's not all of them but it's the core
customers without your proposition how
you're gonna make money
what are your cost whatever partner's
activities resources etc but then we say
you need to get out of the building and
test those hypotheses and buy test them
I don't just mean here's a product you
want to buy it that's selling I mean
getting out an understanding deeply what
are the customer problems what are their
needs and what kind of solution might
actually solve them and so not only do
you talk to those customers you build
something called Minimum Viable products
because the third piece of lean is using
agile engineering to instead of specking
an entire solution and then building it
and shipping it and finding out people
who don't want it you build the product
incrementally and iteratively and you
continually interact with those
customers trying to understand whether
you're on the right track these three
components business model design
customer development and agile
engineering is the Lean Startup
now it's nice we put together a great
theory but what happened so let me tell
you about the theory it started when I
wrote a book called the four steps the
Epiphany that's kind of articulated the
customer and development process and
kind of the problem and we were trying
to solve this gap between search and
execution Alexander Osterwalder wrote a
book called business model generation
describe the business model canvas and
then my best student Eric Ries Lauder
wrote a book called wing startup in fact
when Eric became a will insert a
practitioner the total available market
for we instead of practitioners doubled
from me to him and in fact today is now
or this week is now lean startup week
there are 5,000 people attending as the
Lean Startup conference in San Francisco
so the Lean Startup movement has truly
caught on and then when Harvard Business
Review put the article the Lean Startup
changes everything on its cover in May
2013 it kind of blessed this notion of
it's lean is not only for startups but
is now for corporations trying to keep
up with disruptive innovation and so the
theory was in place but still there
really wasn't a class that taught all
these components let me just remind you
up to 2011 at Stanford University let
alone any other University if you wanted
to take the capstone innovation and
entrepreneurship course in engineering
or the business school or anywhere else
you'd be taking how to write a business
plan class that was the state of
entrepreneurial education because
anybody was dumb or we were wrong we
just didn't know what goes next so we
created something different in 2011 we
said let's teach students
entrepreneurship and lean methods by
simulating a startup let's to have
students work on their own ideas but
create startup pressures and
uncertainties challenges and chaos and
so we started a class here called the
lean launchpad engineering 245 in stvp
number one key differences the class is
experiential every week our students
have to get out and talk to 10 to 15
customers partners regulators etc a week
and they have to build the Minimum
Viable Product that is a incremental
prototype weekly based on what they
learned and they use the lean
methodology and what's normally lectures
are now actually homework we built the
first MOOC in 2011 for an
entrepreneurship class its team-based
it's not students sitting reading cases
students apply as teams of four and
these are student originated problems so
the components they validate the problem
first as I said they use Minimum Viable
products to understand the value they
get out of the building and they draw
lots of pictures
how does stuff work how's the customers
connect what's the market look like etc
what happened was I think kind of
gratifying for all of us so this first
class 2011 has now taught in over 75
other universities over 1200 teams of
students have been through it but more
interesting for all of us is that same
year I blogged every week of the class I
got a call from the head of
commercialization the National Science
Foundation that said we think you
invented the scientific method for
entrepreneurship we've been trying to
teach our scientists to want to
commercialize their science who are
about to get an SBIR grant that is
funding from the US government we still
don't know what to teach them after 30
years we want to try a prototype of your
class fast-forward six years that's now
called the National Science Foundation
innovation core it's our Stanford class
we've put over a thousand teams of the
best scientists and engineers in the
country through this it's taught in 53
other universities and we took those
lectures put them online we have over
three hundred thousand students who've
taken those classes and in 2014 I
prototype the version of the class at
UCSF for therapeutics devices
diagnostics and digital health and by
week four the nih came out and said
we'll take it and so
clock or went from NSF into NIH then the
National Security Agency picked it up in
2015 and then we're going to be talking
about hacking for defense and hacking
for diplomacy that's what happened with
lean and lean innovation classes what's
really interesting is lean
entrepreneurship now provided us with
the key part of the missing piece of oh
it was necessary to build an
entrepreneur ecosystem and that is
management tools not designed for large
companies but management tools for
startups so customer development agile
engineering business model design my
work Oscar Walters work
David Kelly's work the D schools work
for design thinking all kind of fit into
now we have a set of tools and actually
work for different environment instead
of execution when you're trying to
understand customers customer needs and
how to efficiently build new products
the last piece I want to talk about is
the threats outside the university and
outside the country and why that led to
hacking for defense and hacking for
diplomacy just as an aside in the Iraq
and Afghanistan war the US Army stood up
or started a group called the Army's
rapid equipping force and their job was
to search for problems that our soldiers
and war fighters had on the ground and
rapidly deliver commercial off-the-shelf
solutions to those problems let me give
you an example and then I'll point out
the colonel who in the audience who
actually built this in 2010 what the
army we're buying were these Hemery
heavily armed MRAP vehicles that solve
the problem
that soldiers in Iraq had which were
improvised explosive devices exploding
outside their unarmored Humvees
so we now delivered up armored vehicles
to Iraq solve that problem or mostly
accept now our troops were in
Afghanistan where they didn't have roads
and instead of driving around like this
this is how they got around the
mountains oops
no Armour what happened well what
happened is I eat the attacks against
this mounted squads were pretty terrific
the Taliban had a pretty interesting
innovation cycle you know they'd start
we'd stop them they'd innovate learn and
change they'd start we stopped them they
innovate and change unto such that we
were losing a lot of soldiers because we
didn't have a way to counter IEDs for
dismounted troops our innovation cycle
looked like this we'd learn and then we
change the problem is guess whose cycle
was faster ours or theirs so the army
decided we needed to do something better
because in between their cycle and ours
we took 4900 casualties before we could
respond so the rapid equipping force was
a mission focus group was focused on
problem sourcing and definition and
basically use networking and crowd
curation and basically something called
the whoo to loop to rapidly get
solutions out in the field and it was
run by Pete Newell Pete went to raise
your hand yeah colonel Pete Newell and
you'll see his picture again next time
dressed up in something different than
what he's wearing here and Pete found
that the real impediments to innovation
in the Army was we didn't understand we
didn't understand the problem we didn't
understand the threat or the environment
war fighters didn't know what they
wanted they wanted to like stop getting
blown up they but they didn't know what
the solution was
we were delivering static solutions with
no plans for a threat that was evolving
yeah here we have a solution that's
great but the enemy is constantly
iterating and we lacked collaborative
information about what kind of
development environment we should be
using and a good chunk of our
organization didn't get promoted if they
took any risk
so in fact people back home we're
getting pretty risk-averse while people
were getting killed on the battlefield
and finally we were hindered by outdated
policies no you can't spend this money
Congress didn't budge well no people are
dying no but it's not in my spec for the
money you could spend and so Pete in the
RTF put together a different philosophy
that said be present be predictive be
intuitive
be inclusive be aggressive and started
delivering solutions now Pete went out
across the country and found commercial
off-the-shelf Shelf solutions that could
either be used right now like a
bulldozer with a new front end or a mini
portable line charge or a small robotics
device and as we started deploying them
as rapidly as they can and the
casualties started to go down equally
fast what Pete Newell in the rapid
equipping force did was essentially
build a Lean Startup methodology you
don't recognize it this is the Lean
Startup but instead of building apps for
the iPhone there's actually building
real-world solutions at speed at speed
and delivering them out on the
battlefield and that's where interesting
things happen for our next two classes
or the hacking four classes came from so
the hacking for defense and hacking for
diplomacy classes are essentially when
DoD and State Department problems meet
the lean methodology I'll use hacking
for defense as an example you take the
US Army's rapid equipping force Pete
decided he didn't want to be a general
he actually wanted to be a civilian in
Silicon Valley good choice Pete thank
you after 30 years and he set up a
company to help the government find
advanced
jacobee mmt partners and then we took my
lean launchpad class and said let's set
up something called hacking for defense
and actually go out to the department of
defense and intelligence communities in
the US and have them give us their
toughest problems their toughest
problems and let's see if we could get
teams of Stanford students interested in
working not on there and their own
problems but on real live US government
problems and by the way we'll scrub
these problems down to an unclassified
level so any student from any country
could take the class here and in other
schools let's see if we could pull that
off
and so the hacking for Defense Charter
was learnt about the nation's threats
and security challenges while working
with innovators inside the Department of
Defense and intelligence community while
we because it's a class teach our
students entrepreneurship while they
engage something dear to my heart
National Public Service and so the for
the first time we ran something called
hacking for defense to apply the Lean
Startup methodology to real problems
offer students an opportunity for
national service
just as a sidebar for me we've run a
40-year experiment in the United States
disconnecting national service with
foreign policy and I think all of you
could make a judgement to see how well
or not that's worked out and today if
students want to engage in national
service you could do teacher America or
AmeriCorps but there really is no formal
way to get involved with the DoD
intelligence community other than intern
for a summer or a year my intent was to
give all of you another vehicle to do
that and solve some really interesting
problems and learn we not reproduce ship
and so the teaching team looked like
this
Pete Newell how I used to dress up and
show filter who's in MS&E and SESAC and
those were the two instructors and me
looked a lot meaner than I did you
didn't want to get it an answer wrong
with these guys right and so Pete and
Joe will actually been in the DoD for
decades help source these problems from
the Department of Defense and we modify
the business model canvas into something
called the mish
model canvas the biggest thing to note
is the Department of Defense and also on
social ventures you don't have revenue
to measure you have mission achievement
or some kind of metric that isn't
monetary so how do you know that you've
been successful and you don't have a
distribution channel but you do have to
worry about deployment one of the
biggest problems the DoD has today my
opinion is they have more demos from
technologists that you'll ever see in
the planning problem isn't demos its
deployment unemployment means figuring
out how to get the money how to get the
right people to sign off how to take
risks etc so our students not worry
about just demos sometimes you need a
demo to get it general to deploy but the
goal is deployment not demos we teach
them how to get money and I mean
personally but how would you get this
thing funded and deployed and given Pete
managed to spend a billion dollars on a
hundred million dollar budget and not
get court-martialed I think he is one of
the world's experts on figuring out how
to spend other people's money and so the
mission model canvas allowed us to put
together problem understanding with a
curated problem ecosystem from the
Department of Defense and start offering
the DoD intelligence community rapid
solutions now here are some of the
problems that our students were working
on we're able sensors for divers
synthetic aperture radar cube sets
detecting catfishing from the National
Security Agency explosive ordnance
disposal etc these were serious real
problems for students who had no idea
what even some of the terms meant I have
to tell you by the end of the class they
all deeply understood the problem they
were either getting underwater building
diving equipment or wearing explosive
ordnance disposal suits or something
else in fact let me show you an example
of one of the team's a : delivery
vehicle team one the seal delivery
vehicle or SDV is an unpressurized water
filled submersible that carries navy
seals from a submarine to a secondary
location we were tasked with providing
real-time feedback and
capturing data to solve long-term health
problems for their divers after getting
out of the building and talking to our
users as well as getting as close as we
could to walking in their shoes we
realized that a vitals monitoring system
was not their most pressing issue we did
not have a product market fit
so we pivoted to improving their
location and communication capabilities
currently for the SDV to get a GPS fix
they must rise to the surface to stand
up an antenna on top of the SGD this
means they must stop and wait at various
def intervals to go through a full dive
profile for the seals in the vehicle if
they rise too quickly they risk giving
the seals within decompression sickness
our solution is a deployable GPS buoy
that will allow the SDV
to stay at death while acquiring an
updated position in 20% of the time we
continued to test if the product we fit
within their current operating
procedures through customer discovery to
test the feasibility of the product we
created a Minimum Viable Product which
could be tested in the pool and in a
high pressure chamber in its current
state the buoy can be submerged over a
hundred feet and draw display and send
an accurate GPS signal to within a meter
we learned about our key partners as
well as dug deep into how the product
would be deployed because of this we
understand the deployment process and
the key partners we need for the GPS
buoy to actually make it into the hands
of SDV team one divers so this was just
one example one team you know none of
this name knew before I think they
didn't know how to swim but that was
about it
now this would be great if it was just a
Stanford class but that really doesn't
create national service so what Pete and
I and Tom Byers who was also part of the
teaching team did was we decided to
scale this class to other universities
with the help of the National Defense
University and so we started with just
one University us by the end of 2017
there'll be 17 other universities
teaching this with 22 government
agencies involved in the class
my goal is after five years much like
the National Science Foundation program
to have 50-plus universities teaching
hacking for defense now that would be
kind of fun just for one year but we
decided let's do something else
turns out the State Department has a
technical representative in Silicon
Valley is Vika Krieger Vika sat through
the hacking for defense class and said
well wait a minute you could solve
problems for the Department of Defense
can you solve real problems for the
State Department and we said sure why
don't we put together that class and so
we just started this September in fact
going on now hacking for diplomacy where
we got a series of problems from state
and the Charter for here is learn about
foreign policy challenges about working
with innovators inside the State
Department and again by teaching our
students entrepreneurship while they
engage in a national public service
again this time the problems are
different
hacking violent extremism on why
designing an informal leadership data
set avoiding space collisions so all of
a sudden using the same methodology
same protocol but working with the
different government agencies so in
summary there are 163 current innovation
entrepreneurship classes at Stanford I
actually think of us as an incubator
with dorms at three classes lean
launchpad hacking for defense hacking
for diplomacy you all can make a
difference and work on some of the
toughest problems that the country has
sign up and for further reading here's
the links to the class so thank you very
much
so we're happy to take any questions we
have five minutes Steve for questions
pardon and repeat the question Steve
well the rest going what yes sir so one
of the nice things about and Steve
repeat the question Silica's thank you
so the question is what about the
intellectual property of the class IP is
open-source unless there's you know some
proprietary code owned by Stanford or
some of its researchers with all the
caveats about Stanford intellectual
property licensing office but all the
slides historically for all the classes
have been on slideshare.net /s blank
feel free to go take a look at there's
over 650 from the National Science
Foundation and from our classes in
multiple universities other questions
yes in the back great question it was
the one we had in the venture capitalist
I thought so the question was how does
the lean methodology work in medical
devices when gee it's all about
regulation and I'll even raise the ante
how does it work in therapeutics where
it's 15 years in the lab what's the MVP
look like there you'll kill somebody
with half of a drug or having me you can
implant half of a device and you know
what happens if their knee goes out and
and the answer is not intuitively
obvious because you would think oh it's
all about the device or the product it
turns out in in life sciences a good
reason why most of those companies fail
are not just the science of the product
but that you didn't understand the
regulatory environment the financing
environment
you didn't understand clinical trials or
clinical endpoints that's a lot of stuff
particularly if you're a scientist or an
engineer and have you've never built one
of these companies before you could
spend an enormous amount of time and
energy and found to find out that your
business model was just untenable let
alone that your technology don't work
maybe the technology worked but there is
no way to make it profitable so our
folks in medical devices spend their
time understanding for example is it a
PMA or 510 K that is what type of
regulatory regime are you gonna have you
know what kind of clinical trials do you
need who's your clinical partner etc
does that answer your question other
questions yes sir professor blank
greetings from Lima Peru my name is Paul
Morales and I come from the maritime or
water trends now I want to make a
question about that do you think that
the strap system or eco system for the
Latin American region could be useful
like the Silicon Valley ecosystems
because useful for hope yeah that's one
other question - so the question is is
the Latin American I'm sorry for the
people in a way because for the growth
developments so if the question is can
an innovation ecosystem in Latin America
be useful for the people of course is
the answer the question is is it can you
emulate the Silicon Valley ecosystem is
that a question that's right I'm trying
to say that
so Silicon Valley has a unique set of
advantages which right now have to do
with density and density not only of
innovation talent but density of capital
we have more risk capital here than many
other places in fact most places in the
world
it isn't that entrepreneurship talent
isn't everywhere it's that
entrepreneurship town
and risk capital are the things that
make entrepreneurship happen at scale
here does that make sense so it isn't
that you couldn't start another
ecosystem it's that the density has some
self-perpetuating value right now
engineering are not seen but the type of
us - yeah hard hard but not impossible
happy to talk to you after the after the
talk we have time for one more note cut
it off okay all right I can't talk that
fast so thank you very much I'm happy to
take more questions
[Applause]